hey everyone this is steven crowder
happy new year
god bless here's to praying that it's a
great one um firstly let's talk about
israel and palestine or for the purposes
of this video um hamas
thursday was the first day of wrath
waged against the nation of israel in
case you didn't know there was an
official
day of wrath waged against israel on
hamas's part
what happened on this day israel kicked
the crap out of them slightly more
i mean hamas what were you thinking you
don't telegraph your blows to
israel say what you want about these
guys but they're some of the toughest
sobs on the planet hamas is like that
kid
in the schoolyard who always threatened
everyone with karate and then when he
really got into a fight he just got
worked hey you guys don't mess with me
ain't no karate
two seconds later
and i know a lot of people have been
siding with palestine there's a lot of
anti-semitism going on some people are
like well you know
the only reason it's like this is
because israel oppresses them
okay let's assume for a minute that
that's true
all right why doesn't palestine just
oppress israel then
well because they can't and why is that
well because they don't have the power
the technology to do so
why is that because because
because and then her head explodes i
know you wouldn't expect it but actually
some craniums have
exploded um in this thought process it's
a scientific fact
the truth is they're right i mean a lot
of these other countries
are living in the dark ages but we have
to ask
why is that israel has arguably the best
military intel in the world
they crap in sand dunes
israel has a high quality of living and
is often at the forefront of modern
technology
they sell rugs why do you think that is
feel free to leave your answer below and
then the un
came out and tried to demand a ceasefire
and israel was like
no no we're not going to do that and the
u.s was all
yeah good going israel yeah you know hey
just forget them you
keep doing what you got to do i mean
does anybody really respect the u.n
anymore i mean if this isn't a complete
display of their total lack of authority
or relevance
they're like that parent who couldn't
even give their kid a time out young man
you're gonna get a time out
israel we demand a ceasefire
now okay and what i want to know is
where's barack obama's stance in all of
this has anyone seen a statement i mean
this man is going to be the leader of
the free world in the next what 16
days is he too busy airbrushing out his
six-pack on the beaches of hawaii
that's another thing why was barack
obama in people's or
star magazine's top ten list of hottie
celebrity physiques
barack obama has the worst kind of body
possible
skinny fat he is a man who manages to
keep a very
small unattractively frail stature
while maintaining virtually zero muscle
mass whatsoever
i guess those cigarettes are catching up
with them here's to hoping you don't
fall off the wagon again big guy
okay some of you out there don't know
where i stand go
team israel you know to israel
listen um despite current trends or
political wins
just know that you guys have some
serious allies here in the states and
we love you we support you in godspeed